ever wondered just how Amazon has been
keeping up with being able to constantly
deliver products to their customers
within a two-day
um note scratch that now one day
timeline successfully thanks to the
introduction of enhanced technology
delivery for a bewildering number of
consumer goods is now not only
conceivable but essentially standard in
today's video we take a look inside
Amazon's fast shipping system how it all
started before Prime launched in 2005
one day shipping was too far-fetched now
it is the standard shipping speed for
Amazon's 100 million Prime members since
2015 Amazon has been making use of a
mind-blowing technological invention
known as deep learning AI what I mean in
simple terms is it's an algorithm that
assesses the category of products that
are likely to be requested by A specific
group of people on a specific date or at
a specific time the algorithm recognizes
specifically what is in Trend products
consumers need the most products that
may be in use during a particular season
and the like this therefore enables
Amazon in to prepare almost if not
everything their customers might need at
different periods in time since 2019
Amazon has begun to double the speed of
prime shipping from two days to one and
the faster speed is now available on
more than 10 million products during an
interview with CNBC Simeon Siegel a
retail Analyst at numura instinet said
Amazon has changed the game completely
so what they excel at is getting an
object from a Creator to a consumer as
flawlessly as they can and as quickly as
they can so Amazon is changing people's
expectations and they are perpetually
improving those expectations yearly
Amazon spends billions of dollars on
shipping and in the last quarter of 2018
Amazon shipping costs increased by 23
percent reaching a record of 9 billion
when a CNBC reporter asked Amazon senior
VP of worldwide operations Dave Clark
whether such a move was worth it he said
customers come to expect consistent fast
delivery of anything on Earth from
Amazon and our job is to continue to
make that happen this is exactly why
Amazon CEO Jeff Bezos said himself
customers all over the world they are
divinely discontent you give them the
best service you can they love it but
they always want a little bit more
Amazon then stored 800 million dollars
just in the second quarter to start
making one-day shipping the standard the
majority of that investment accounts for
costs related to infrastructure and
transportation to accelerate delivery to
the increasing number of prime customers
by relying on other postal services such
as UPS DHL Etc Amazon however thought to
take a step towards controlling this
process better and the large costs that
came with it by first halting its
Reliance on these postal services and
then substantially investing in its own
network of logistics before you order I
already mentioned earlier that Amazon
uses a particular AI known as the
algorithm in order to detect products
that will be requested by customers at a
particular time let's get deeper into
this process take one of Amazon's most
ordered clothing items a winter coat as
an example say you need winter coats to
prepare for the season how will Amazon
deliver the coats to your door the
following day well thanks to this
fantastic algorithm your coat Journey
has begun before you even thought to
purchase it popularly needed items are
already packed and made available in
stock in the warehouse so in the case of
your winter coats Amazon's algorithm
already recognizes the winter season and
surely anticipates customers like you
who take early precautionary measures to
prepare for the season so before the
chill begins to rush in Amazon already
has winter clothes and protective gear
in stock for you amazing yeah the
Fulfillment center after the algorithm
process the products which have already
been identified by this AI are moved to
a place known as the Fulfillment center
thanks to this amazing retail Enterprise
there are already about 175 gigantic
fulfillment centers across the globe and
since Amazon plans to construct more of
these you can bet that a warehouse
within a day's drive with you will
undoubtedly contain a winter coat take
it from me inside those fulfillment
centers is where the true magic occurs
millions of items are stored here many
of them quite obviously owned by Amazon
but surprisingly more than half of the
products that are stored here belong to
other manufacturers the FBA fully known
as the Fulfillment by Amazon program was
introduced in 2006 as a means for other
businesses to benefit from Amazon's
outstanding shipping service this
program enables small businesses to pay
Amazon for the logistics thereby fully
reaching their customers potential and
ultimate satisfaction companies like DHL
and UPS whom Amazon used to rely on for
Logistics before now turn to Amazon for
Logistics assistance so a winter coat
manufacturer to follow our example does
not have to worry about constructing
their fulfillment centers and Logistics
operation they just pay Amazon to do it
for them this means that if you order an
item just know and rest assured that the
item has been sent to Amazon to ensure
that you receive your orders quickly how
all of these products are packed and
stored at the Fulfillment center is even
more astonishing and I've got all the
the details for you the storing and
picking process you might imagine that
in large warehouses products would be
stored sectionally for instance all
winter coats will be arranged in one
section but that is not the case in
Amazon's Warehouse in fact items are
stored at random when a shipment of say
100 winter coats arrives in a truck from
the manufacturer at Amazon's fulfillment
center each will be stored in any
available space on the Shelf okay okay I
know you may be wondering just how then
would they be able to get the items when
needed as soon as possible now listen
the location of these items is carefully
recorded on the computer this means that
when you click on the buy Now icon for
your winter coat a bot or a human picker
is tasked to walk to the location of the
code statistically at least if every
item is stored at random there is a very
high chance that one of the 100 winter
coats is likely to be nearby and easily
reachable you may have read or heard
rumors about how Amazon employees are
required to travel miles of Warehouse
floors to pick up products well that
isn't so at least not anymore and I'll
tell you why robotic intervention as of
2012 robots have played a bigger role in
the picking process to the point where
in most fulfillment centers now the
shelves moved to the human picker for
any products that need to be picked or
stored Amazon purchase robotics company
Kiva for 775 million dollars and began
utilizing robots in its fulfillment
centers and Warehouse a few years later
again using the winter coat example it
can be picked up by one of these bots in
about 15 minutes as opposed to up to an
hour by a human picker additionally
there are now robots that can move
merchandise lift pallets and boxes using
robotic arms and even package Goods in
custom design boxes in a way to further
establish a faster picking process
Amazon introduced wristbands which are
to be worn by the workers whilst in the
warehouse this gadget vibrates to tell
them where the item is where exactly on
the Shelf to grab it to store a product
the result it's encouraged the workers
to speed up their work process with
sophisticated interfaces that gamify
their jobs damn that I'd have to walk
and I'd much rather be up here in my own
little world picking than walking up and
down so I love the robotic
rotation Center and shipping after being
picked an item will subsequently be sent
to a location known as the sortation
center here millions of outgoing
shipments are successfully sorted
according to postal address by a variety
of robots which are believed to be
approximately one hundred thousand
according to reports delivery rate Rose
after Amazon switched from using human
sorters to a robot-led operation and
delivery turnaround time followed suit
it is fantastic to watch how the items
are sorted and packaged it's like a
large playground for a package there are
conveyor belts that go round there are
slides too it all looks like a lot of
fun to me while some items are being
shipped out using one of the delivery
Giants Amazon is now saving money by
sending shipments in at least 300 of its
semi-trucks and now dozens of its
airplanes in a conversation with CNBC
Amazon senior vice president of
worldwide operations Dave Clark says we
have been building out an air Network
for several years now that coupled with
our partners networks we are in a place
where we have a lot of incremental
capacity to be able to advance packages
for customers much faster than we were
two or three years ago Amazon currently
provides ocean cargo Services between
the United States and China and owns at
least 50 airplanes 300 semi trucks and
20 000 delivery vans last mile delivery
once an item gets delivered close to
your city it waits in another Warehouse
similar to this one until a delivery guy
comes by to pick it up and bring it to
your doorstep anyone who is well
acquainted with Logistics will tell you
that the most difficult part of any
delivery cycle is this last mile
delivery but in this particular area
Amazon outperforms its competitors due
to the size of its operation one thing
is clear and it is that Amazon can
demand significant savings from
established shipping companies like UPS
or DHL in 2019 according to research
conducted by Financial Juggernaut Morgan
Stanley he said that by 2022 Amazon will
be dispatching 6.5 billion packages
annually I must say that's a lot of
products and a lot of money money too as
a result Amazon is increasingly making
the final mile itself in some regions up
to 56 percent of Amazon packages are
currently delivered directly by Amazon
how keep watching introducing Amazon
Flex brought to the Limelight in 2015
one of the remarkable ways Amazon uses
to deliver its last mile delivery
products is through Amazon Flex anyone
can become a delivery driver as a result
of this newly introduced feature as it
enables drivers to accept directives
just by using a smartphone this
indicates that you can receive your
winter clothing from Amazon via last
mile delivery as a top priority not in a
crammed container but in a personal taxi
given that this recently developed
method of last mile delivery is
relatively lucrative as these agents are
reportedly paid up to 25 per hour Amazon
has offered for its staff to launch
their own Last Mile package delivery
business as opposed to working full-time
in Amazon warehouses or its fulfillment
centers Jeff Wilkie Amazon CEO of
worldwide consumer said in an interview
with c MBC that over 16 000 employees
have already taken us up on this You Now
understand how quickly Amazon can send
your package to you which is by making
sure that the item you desire is in
stock even before you're aware that you
need it being stored in a location that
makes it simple for the Picker to get it
and thanks to the helpful Bots that
assist with this operation as well as
the last mile delivery drivers your
parcel can be delivered to you in a
matter of hours what's your opinion on
Amazon shipping system if you like this
video make sure to click a card on your
screen for more content like this